let's focus in more on this issue of how
we're treating members of the military
right now III I'm truly sick of the
current president mocking and ridiculing
members of the military and just
generally not being good to people in
the military the latest is that Trump
mocked Lieutenant Colonel Alexander VIN
Minh in his first public appearance
since his hospital visit specifically he
mocked VIN Minh for wearing his military
uniform then he also mocked last week's
witness George Kent for his bowtie take
a look at this as he says Lieutenant
Colonel I understand somebody had the
misfortune of calling him mister and he
corrected them I never saw the man I
understand now he wears this uniform
when he goes in no I don't know vinda
Minh at all what I do know is that even
he said that the transcript was correct
and if anybody reads the transcript I
had two calls with the president of
Ukraine who by the way said there was no
pressure whatsoever there was no
anything they don't they probably think
they can't they probably can't even
understand what's going on with this
country but VIN Minh I watched him for a
little while this morning and I think he
I'm gonna let people make their own
determination but I don't know ven Minh
I never heard of him I don't know any of
these people other than I have seen one
or two a couple of times they're
ambassadors but these are names Senator
Mike Taylor like Kent with the nice
bowtie wonderful bowtie maybe I'll get
one for myself someday
I don't know Kent is I don't know who
Taylor is this is how you know they're
beat in Trump's case I don't think he
actually has the attention span or the
cognitive capacity to sit through to
listen to to understand the witnesses
the devastating testimony from people
like Lieutenant Colonel bin Minh and
today from Gordon Sunland but that's
another story but look at the trend on
substance Republicans are unable to
refute the obvious bad acting of Trump
and the people around him with regard to
Ukraine and that will become even more
impossible after Gordon
testimony today and then we get to trump
who again is going after members of the
military despite claiming that he's all
about the troops attacking the late
Senator John McCain because he got
captured and tortured and Trump prefers
military heroes who don't get captured
attacking and fighting with the parents
of a soldier who lost his life as an
army captain serving the US military
implying that veterans with PTSD just
aren't strong enough as I mentioned
earlier calling all sorts of generals
who have actual knowledge and experience
clueless claiming he knows more than the
generals he knows more than the
intelligence community he knows more
than everybody who serves the u.s. in
some way shape or form claiming that
he's donating money to veterans to get a
PR benefit and then not actually
donating the money there's no limit to
the sickening buffoonery but it is so
acutely disrespectful to a group that
Trump said he would respect Trump said
he would support them but more
importantly this is a group forget about
Trump for a second cuz he'll eventually
be gone this is a group that Republicans
in Trump's party claim to respect and
support where are the Republicans on
Trump's constant and persistent
disregard and disdain for members of the
military like Lieutenant Colonel VIN
Minh why can't they say hey you know
what I don't think Trump should be
impeached but there's no evidence that
we should be a sailing ving man's
character the the attacks on him are not
based in any kind of fact and Donald
Trump needs to stop right away I would
like to see them come forward and say
that now as far as VIN moons uniform
this is not my area of expertise I was
under the impression that if you're an
active military member if you go to
court or government proceedings like
House of Representatives proceedings
you're supposed to wear your uniform I
was I mean I I'm going off the top of my
head if I'm wrong I am will gladly
correct myself but that's the impression
that I was under and I truly don't
understand where this is even coming
from and why not we're hearing pushback
by the way Trump you know criticized VIN
Minh there for correcting Devin Nunez
who called him mister and said actually
I go by
lieutenant colonel we looked at that
video earlier on in the show and it's
extremely enjoyable I hope that you will
check it out because it is it's
something else
Devon unis getting visibly uncomfortable
when he's corrected by Lieutenant
Colonel VIN Minh but Trump again why are
you going after members of the military
all the time and really when you're
under impeachment the focus is what the
witnesses were wearing George Kent's
bowtie and Alexander VIN man's military
uniform you know they've lost or you
know they simply don't even understand
what's going on when the focus is what
the witness is the devastating witnesses
to Trump's narrative we're wearing
clothes that Trump found unusual or
worth commenting on these guys are
pathetic